Let's talk a bit more about the behavior of these exponential decay and
exponential growth functions. In particular, what are their domains and ranges?
The functions that are graphed here are y equals one half to the x. Or now you
know, this is the same as y equals 2 to the negative x. And over here, we have
y equals 2 to the x. For each function, please use interval notation to write
in the domain and range. Although using the graphs can be helpful to answer
this question, the equations are also really useful. For each domain, try to
see if there are any values of x that produce invalid answers when plugged into
the function. And for the range, think about what values the function can and
can't take on.